- [Kelly Clarkson] People
don't realize if you
even if you are older and never had kids
so much going after you have a baby
like not only your body, is just given up.
Um, but your emotional
state is kind of crazy.
So, like somebody
talking to someone that's
just had a baby in a photo shoot saying,
Oh, you need to lose some weight.
That will send you in a spiral.
- Oh, yeah no the hormones are crazy
and no one talks about it! The hormones
after pregnancy, for me were crazier
than when I was pregnant.
And it took forever for them to calm down.
Like, months after breastfeeding,
I mean, uh I think I
might still be hormonal.
(laughter)
- No, here's my best,
this is my best story
So, I was, I freaked
out 'cause I had, I was
pumping so I was working the same time
- Which is the worst!
- Pumping is the worst!
- The worst!
- It's so painful! I don't
care what anyone says.
Anyway, but, somebody
had kind of tossed out
and it was only a tiny
bit of breast milk left
in the bottle.
- No! No!
- [Kelly] I lost my ever
living my, like a crazy person
went in my closet and just bleugh like
- Oh yah!
- Collapsed on the floor and was crying
'cause I was like, you
have no idea how hard
I worked for that. And I was like, really
there was like nothing in the bottle.
I'm crazy, but it literally it's just
a hormonal period and I don't think people
take that into account, especially when
we're women in the public eye,
- Yeah
- [Kelly] Like, it is a hard time.
- And our energy is comp, is literally
being sucked out of us, so you don't
feel like yourself, you don't
- Literally, it's being sucked out of you.
- [Kate] Literally! It's
being sucked out of you.
It is so difficult and something
people need to talk about more.
- Um, I hundred percent. I talk about it
any chance I can, I
complain about pregnancy
and all of that any chance I can.